okay um good evening everybody and
welcome to this evening's reconvened
meeting a planning and development
management committee just very briefly
uh by way of introduction my name is
adam williams i'm the chair of the
committee also present this evening uh
councillor ben hartley the committee's
vice chair
um officers from the council's legal
service democratic service planning
service and the local highway authority
as well as the elected members who serve
as the voting members of the planning
committee um just before we proceed
through the business this evening i just
want to raise for everyone's attention
that this meeting has been live streamed
and recorded and it will be available
for viewing on the council's website
um but just note some apologies from
members who haven't been able to join us
um this evening there's been council of
i canola councilman stanley and
councillor bunting
and hopefully councillor thomas will be
joining us at some point
um so we'll turn now to agenda item six
which is applications for permission to
develop and the first application that
we'll consider this evening is 107.03
which is 40 byram street in hail and can
be found on page 95 of the committee
report and before we hear from speakers
the application is going to be
introduced by ms milner
thank you chair
so the first application before members
relates to 40 byron street in orchard
it's a two-story terrace property the
application proposes the direction of
single-story rare extensions
one projecting from the main elevation
and one from the two-story
outrigger
this is just the existing plans
one objection was received from the
neighborhood number 38 which was
supported by councillor mrs young who
requested the application be called
planning committee
the application i'm sorry the objection
raised concerns regarding the extension
resulting in an overcrowding
overcrowding on the boundary loss of
light loss of direct sunlight and
overshadowing into the window and french
doors and that the proposal would not
comply with the 45 degree rule
and it would create a tunneling effect
along the boundary and set a precedent
for the area and limit access to the
boundary wall for repairs and
maintenance and also objected to the
height of the wall adjacent to the
boundary the rear extension adjacent to
number 38 would have a depth of 30 so
of 3 meters
and a height of three meters being cited
half a meter from the boundary it would
therefore comply with the guidance
within sbd4 and officer con officers
consider that due to the scale it would
not result in undue harm to the
occupiers of number 38.
the extension from the outrigger
would replace an existing outbuilding
and given its sighting and scale is also
not considered to result in harm to
amenity of surrounding occupiers
the contemporary design approach is
supported and given the scale and the
single-story nature of the proposal the
extension is considered
proportionate within the plot while
consideration has been given to the
comments received it is considered the
proposal does comply with adopted policy
and guidance and as such is recommended
for approval
and just to aid officers here are some
photographs so
your photograph on your left is looking
at the rear elevation of the application
site and with the french doors to the
left of the objector the photo on the
right is um dwellings to the rear of the
application property and again this is
just looking either side of the
application site at the rear
and also just for clarity i was asked to
explain the 45 degree rule which is
mentioned in the objection and is picked
up in
um the officer report so the 45 degree
rule
is commonly used throughout and planning
depart departments to assess extensions
and but it is not within trafford's
guidelines so it is not something that
you will see officers referring to or
using as a tool for assessment within um
our householder applications and it is
used by a number of departments as a
rule of thumb but we have sbd4 and the
measurements within that and therefore
we do not refer to
um the 45 degree wall thank you
thank you um registered to speak against
the application uh ms hughes and
counselor young
know who'd like to speak first
hi
and thanks for joining us then if you
just before you speak if you can just
make sure the microphones on it should
sort of glow a green color on the button
and red on the tip um you've got three
minutes to speak and if you just run
over time i'll politely ask that you
wrap up your contribution thank you okay
um thank you for the opportunity to
speak today the proposed extension will
greatly reduce the limited space in our
extremely overcrowded area thus causing
a tunneling effect for us our outdoor
space is again extremely limited and
every inch of space of light is
extremely important to us also the
amended plans are very close to the
original plan submitted last year with
the corners cut to make sure it goes
through the planning application but it
has little effect to what will
happen on our side i must say at this
point the defining reason for buying our
house was the southwest facing yard
although half of it is in shadow because
the large houses behind on willow tree
road we currently enjoy sun on our
decking in the afternoon
in our south
facing backyard the proposed extension
will dramatically reduce our light into
our kitchen and our dining room
as a terraced house is a notoriously
dark five years ago we installed the
french doors into our dining room to let
full hat to the full height plus a
window above to maximize the light we
get in the particular area
practically 50 of our washing line will
permanently be in shadow we don't have
much space to hang washing out but we
make them the best of what we've got and
half of this will be taken away
the half that will be cast in shadow
currently enjoys the heat of the sun
when it's at its highest and this will
force us force us to use a tumble dryer
as energy prices continue to rise
we have a raised decking off the french
doors where we sit and enjoy the
afternoon sun
and
this will be shattered shrouded in
shadow this is the biggest bonus to
living in this house the beautiful
afternoon sun our kitchen window faces
the proposed extension and currently
enjoys afternoon and early evening sun
which is a family space that will be
darkened the french doors cast light
into our dining room which is obviously
a family space where we have a lovely
big family table this is where we eat
our girls do our homework we socialise
and it'll now be in shadow my husband
and i work from home i personally work
on this dining table and it enables zoom
meetings if there's planning permission
it'll be dark the full day the mental
health impact of living in darkness will
be huge of two young girls they're 13
and 15 who've enjoyed the past two years
and locked down and this was our only
outdoor space if light is reduced it'll
be sad for us as a family should we go
into lockdown again we'll have no
outdoor space in the sun the proposed
extension glass roof would be arm's
reach to my youngest daughter's bedroom
window which will make it uncomfortable
due to the lack of privacy and will
cause light pollution into her window at
night
the original plan was that we would
collaborate with our neighbour and also
create an extension we were always
mindful of the reduction of light we may
face ultimately investigations were made
and we were unable to afford the 50 000
pound minimum it would cost to build a
six metre square extension my husband
has recently made redundant and i'm glad
we did not commit to this expensive pro
expensive project
it is a project that should benefit both
parties not greatly disadvantage one
side to the advantage of the other we
live happily in our house for 13 years
we've brought our girls up here and
we've considered building this kind of
sad return but knowing the impact on our
neighbours will be huge we've
dismissed the idea it's sad this hearing
has had to happen
thank you thank you for your uh comments
um counselor young do you want to take
the same seat and just
um provide your contribution and you
have five minutes to speak thank you
i'd like to support the statement made
by mrs hughes
as her whole family is really concerned
of the alarming possibility of their
future living area of the house
being in semi-darkness should you decide
to grant this application in its present
form
i'm not sure whether any of you have
actually visited number 38 byram street
to see for yourselves just why they are
so concerned
i have
and i can confirm that in my opinion
should this extension be allowed in its
current form
it will be necessary to have the
electric light switched on whenever mr
mrs hughes used the dining room for
working in or for the children to do
their homework
and looking out of the dining room and
kitchen windows will have a similar
aspect to what you would see if you're
looking out of the window in a converted
cellar and you're looking through a
tunnel of brick
it's not very pleasant
extensions are often accused of causing
problems to close neighbors
and a reasonable amount of income of
inconvenience can always be expected
should your neighbor decide to build one
but in this particular case i believe
that mr and mrs hughes right to be so
concerned
number 38 byram street is in a very
overcrowded over-built area of trafford
there can't be many more areas in
trafford that have such a limited amount
of space between adjoining buildings and
streets the backyard areas between byram
street and willow tree road being
particularly miniscule
this means that number 38 is closely
overlooked by some five or six other wet
other dwellings
and the hues accept this but they are
concerned of the deprivation of light
and air that this proposed extension
would cause should it be allowed
paragraph seven of the officers report
says that policy l7 of the core strategy
states that in relation to matters of
immunity
developments must not prejudice the
immunity of future occupiers of the
development
and or occupants of adjacent properties
by reason of overbearing overshadowing
overlooking
visual intrusion noise or disturbance
odor in any other way
paragraph 8 specifically states that it
is important that extensions alterations
do not cause a significant loss of light
to windows in neighboring properties
and or their patio and garden areas
this report concludes that this proposal
comprises an appropriate form of
development for the site
i'm sorry to say that i disagree with
this statement and i hope that you will
refuse this application
and let
let you know on the grounds of the lack
of immunity and loss of light
to the
to the
anyway thank you
thank you thank you councillor young
are there any members wishing to
open the discussion to this application
i saw a few of you then account for the
maitland sorry
thank you um has there been any um
i don't know the exact words that you
would use
um to test the light um and the effect
that this would be this would cause
a light assessment no we we don't ask
for
you like a daylight sunlight sorry
daylight light adjustments no we don't
ask for assessments on applications of
this scale
and we use spd4 which provides um
guidelines on what we consider to be
acceptable and
general acceptable kind of depths
and and so with this one because it's
three meters in depth
and 0.5 meters so half a meter from the
boundary it would actually be
um it would go
in
it's better than what we would usually
accept so we usually say three meters
and plus the distance to the boundary
but this is three meters but with a
separation to the boundary so it's more
of a judgment call on this scale of
application
thank you
thank you come to the welton
yeah this is a these really tough these
ones it is an incredibly tight um
site
um and you know you can see that the
other properties have yet to
in just in those those few houses around
it that they seem to
be yet to uh
to put extensions on
but it's not a huge extension and it's
um
and there seems to be a very little that
we can kind of hang it on in planning
terms in terms of you know in terms of
of a refusal at the moment obviously
there's
there is the community aspect of it but
then you know as
the applicant was saying that they would
be interested you know if it wasn't for
the finances then they would be
interested in building an extension
themselves and which would suggest that
they're you know
that that it
that it's uh you know this is something
that that they would find desirable and
obviously their neighbor finds it
desirable there isn't any plan a great
planning reason not to do it so i'm at
the moment i'm minded to grant but i'd
really like to hear what everybody else
is
is saying thank you
thank you counselor
i don't disagree with councillor welton
said however i i believe that the uh
representatives said that they were
thinking of building an extension in
conjunction so i think that would be
slightly different to building on
independently
i don't not necessarily planning terms
but in practical terms
um council shocking
thank you um
like councilor welton it's a it's a it's
a bit of a hard one it is it's a very
small space
i do appreciate that the applicant has
made a lot of changes to the previous
submission
and
has tried to find something that will
work and
within within our guidelines
looking at it
i i am concerned that it will cause some
loss of immunity to number 38 but
like miss milner said it's it's a
judgment call i don't think
i'm not sure it's enough to say we can
turn it down based on on that i don't
think it is it's not going to cause
enough loss of immunity to 38 but
without an assessment you can't you
can't say for certain so i am of two
minds on this one i'll be honest um
thank you councillor dagnan
i i don't know that i don't know the
answer to this it seems to me that the
amenity of these houses with the with
the
site space that they've got is pretty
limited anyway so it seems
i suppose what i'm saying what i'm
trying to do is appreciate the impact in
the context that it's in so some of the
things around us
whatever for
um
would
would seem make this seem extremely
reasonable another context but in this
context it does seem extremely tight and
any loss of immunity when they've got
such a limited amount of space and light
is going to be more impactful than a lot
of the other developments that we have
before us on a regular basis
so i i don't know either
but
thank you councillor hartley
i'm i'm tournament as well to be honest
i went and had a look um at number 40
and i went in uh number 38 as well i met
this hughes
and and i can understand the the impact
particularly on the loss of light um it
will have an impact on the light i think
going to um the rear of number 38 to
those patio doors and
i think i was helped in that by the time
of day that i went which was in the
evening so
the sun so i think the rear is sort of
west maybe west south west facing so the
sun was sort of
setting at the back of the houses and
you you could sort of see how it would
interfere with that direct light into
those windows so it will have an impact
i suppose the question is whether that
is um you know an overbearing impact
and the difficulty is it does comply
with the the guideline distances in spd4
um
but they are on the guidelines and
equally um
paragraph eight in the report does sort
of set out some of the other parts of
spd4 around um
do not cause a significant loss of light
to windows in neighbouring properties
and other patio and garden areas
and the following paragraph talks about
the
the size position design of the
extension but also the orientation of
the property so i think
i think it's particularly challenging
because the orientation of of of these
properties and
i think as council of diagonal says you
know the limited the limited immunity
space at the moment
um i couldn't i went around the back as
well and down the back alley i couldn't
i couldn't see a similar extension
to this on on the hoses there a lot of
the houses had extended upwards and put
dormas on the back um
and and you know they are quite tight um
quite tight terraces so i'm i'm quite
torn because
i think you could sort of argue it
either way almost on spd4 but um
at the moment i'm probably minded to say
grant and because it does comply with
those guidelines uh on the distances
and
the guidelines are obviously written
with
a range of household extensions in mind
and a range of
you know orientations in mind so i don't
think we can
disapply those guideline distances just
because the house happens to be south or
southwest facing i think that's the
problem so
yeah i do have sympathy with with the
neighbors at number 38 but i suspect
that um this is one where
the guidance would suggest that we would
we should grant but i'll wait to hear
what people to say
thank you just on that question of
whether it's sbd4 compliant in terms of
distances because when i was reading
paragraph um
10 through 12
it looks as though
there is quite a significant breach in
the distance standard the separation
distance and i was just wondering
is that is that the case that we've
accepted quite a significant spd for
distance breach there and if i'm reading
that correctly it's suggesting that
we're tolerating that in this instance
because it's only a single story aspect
of the extension
yes what what we've noted in in that
section of the report is the distance to
the rear boundary i think as as members
have picked up on the the rear gardens
are quite small so we've accepted there
is uh a breach in the tim 10.5 meter
rule and that is seeking to protect the
amenity of neighbours to the rear
but i think also noted in the report is
that there's an alleyway that
runs between
this road and the road to the rear
therefore providing a further separation
and because it's single story it's not
considered that although there's a fall
to the rear boundary that development
would be
um overbearing or resulting in a loss of
privacy
and also if i could just pick on sbd4 i
think um
councillor diagnosed point about
it not applying in all cases and spd4
was written um using the permitted
development guidelines and as kind of a
starting point and permitted development
allows
three meter extensions on terrace and
semi-detached properties
with a number of caveats but it is kind
of the um accepted standard um
nationally and that's that's why we've
used it thank you
thank you um
no i think i agree with what other
members have said and this is quite a
challenging application really because
it's such a unique um plot
there are any
members who haven't spoken who wish to
contribute
no
conscious we haven't had um emotion
for approval or refusal moved either
counselor
is
uh councilman welton
sorry um how
so how much by how much does this exceed
the permitted development um you know
what they could build through permitted
development
um
in terms of depth it doesn't in terms of
height it doesn't um
it's a question of materiality and it's
pretty much
um
it could be it could be permitted
development in some cases
um but they've applied for planning
permission so we
we apply our development plan as a whole
but we and therefore we don't go into
the full depth because we haven't we
haven't looked at it quickly into
permitted development and you could
question the materiality but i think
that would be a judgment call um but i
think in terms of dimensions it's it is
it's pretty much there
can you define materiality for me please
sorry
so within um the permitted development
it says materials you must look the same
as the existing building or similar to
they're proposing white render this
property has white painted bricks at the
back
and
therefore it's not identical but it is
similar and i think if we were looking
at this from an enforcement point of
view we'd probably rule on the side of
it being um similar um but again i'm not
making a formal judgment on whether this
is permitted development that that is
separate to this application but i think
what i can say with confidence is that
three meters is within the boundaries
and it doesn't have the um i think it's
also the width um is
would be
um so i'm just going to look quickly i
think it's less than half the width of
the original dwelling and therefore they
probably would
um
fall within
potentially
um
[Music]
okay um
given that
this the basis of size it could be
it could be built in under permitted
development anyway
sorry is that what we see
a permissive development scheme could
actually be bigger
and because
not in depth but it could be up to the
boundary and it could go up to four
metres high
yeah on that basis i'm happy to propose
the motion to grant um yeah and not not
happily but i just don't i can't see
that a rejection is going to get us very
far
understood thank you um
any other members
looking to contribute
no
on that basis then i i suppose i agree
really that
if the position would be that this could
likely be approved under permitted
development i will second your motion um
counselor
so anybody who wishes to move a counter
motion or make a comment
no okay so that motion is the
um
application being answered permission in
line with officer recommendation
members supporting that motion can
indicate now please
okay
thank you very much um
thank you for attending this evening as
well um we'll now turn to application
107 309 which is first primary school in
sale and can be found on page 103 of the
committee report
before we hidden speakers the
application is going to be introduced by
mr day
thank you chair
um this application has been reported to
the planning and development management
committee because traffic council is the
applicant
an objection has been received
the application relates to first primary
school which occupies a large site
to the southeast of furs road in sale
the school has recently expanded to
accommodate three-form entry
which has included the erection of a
single story nursery block
and two-story classroom block
the remaining buildings at the site are
primarily single-story structures with
playing fields to their south east and
west
this application consists of the
erection of a canopy and the
installation of five air conditioning
units to the standalone nursery block
letters of objection have been received
from one neighboring property on the
grounds of security
nuisance and damage to property
the primary considerations are therefore
the impacts that propose on visual
immunity residential immunity and
security
so you can see the
the corner of the school site that that
it relates to
their uh adjacent to 121 furs road
plans showing the proposed canopy
from the side of the nursery building
and a photograph um showing the nursery
building on the left-hand side and the
adjacent
121 furs road
um
the carpet has been moved further away
from the site boundary in accordance
with advice from
gm police designed for security
the nuisance console t raises no
objection in principle but recommends
that a noise impact assessment in
relation to the air conditioning units
is submitted within two months of
permission being granted
subject to appropriate conditions the
canopy and air conditioning units
are considered to be acceptable in terms
of visual amenity
residential immunity and security
officers consider the proposal according
to the development plan and therefore
recommend that permission is granted
subject conditions
thank you
thank you um statement opposing the
development has been provided by mr
murphy which will be read out by ms
coley
thank you chair just just to make
members aware that there's some personal
information this statement which i'm not
going to read out we did ask
the objector if they wanted it read out
when they didn't have a response so i'm
not reading the full statement on that
basis i'm leaving out that personal
information
concerns over planning application um as
follows security we have always felt
that our home is secure from all sides
this will no longer be the case as our
single-story roof will become vulnerable
becoming just a stride away criminals
look out for exactly these situations
your actions will make us a target the
noise will be condensed into a small
area under our bedroom window amplified
by the containment
shift work nights will become a
nightmare i understand this will not be
every day but i'm aware of the days
where music dance playing of instruments
have been played in the past will this
be moved to the new proposed covered
area the school land is immense compared
to our small solace without exaggeration
i've been verbally abused by parents
witnessed by school staff who stayed and
monitored my safety i've had a constant
battle with people not only parking over
my drive but also on it we've had the
builders smash the corner of our garage
when the temporary building was being
installed which they denied at first and
then swiftly paid for the damage we've
had all sorts of objects thrown into our
garden stick stones etc we've made the
staff aware of this but no change we
knew what we were signing up for when
buying a house next to a nursery this
has far exceeded these expectations and
now the ever closer encroachment will
feel we don't even have our quiet space
in the garden or even our bedroom thank
you
thank you um any members looking to open
the discussion to this item counselor
diagnol
i don't know if you can answer this but
i am curious what is the purpose of the
canopy
i understand that it would obviously
allow um
some kind of
play space to to to operate during
inclement weather so i mean
as as it's kind of explained in the
report there is um there is already a
hard surface yard wrapping around the
nursery building where outdoor play
might be
possible but obviously this will extend
the
the periods of time when when children
could be outside yeah i'm just i'm just
aware i mean i i appreciate that i
argued almost conversely last week that
the nice restrictions on the nursery
planned elsewhere
and should be removed but it does seem
um
it does seem almost contrary to have
such a huge amount of space and then to
put children in that area that runs
right alongside somebody's house
as a as a ex-nursing professional i
personally wouldn't want children
playing in an area that wasn't clearly
viewed from anywhere and that site
did look like it couldn't be easily
viewed from anywhere so i'm not quite
sure
i'm not quite sure that it would be fit
for purpose anyway but it does seem very
very close to encouraging children to
play in that particular area i do have
some sympathy with the neighbour
thank you councillor thomas
thank you chad
is the
2.2 metre separation to the side
boundary after the reduction in size
yeah that's that's as i'm ended that so
yeah the gap to the boundary has been
increased um to 2.2 meters yeah
and the air conditions are going
underneath the canopy as well under air
conditioning units at ground level
yeah sorry should i just get them leave
you in mind
again um
the air conditioning units are on the
side of the building you can actually
see them on
on that photograph so there's three on
the side
of the building and there's two on the
rear of the building that you can't
actually see but
further away from the property
so in that case it's not actually a hard
standings it's grassed
well you said it was a hard standing
wrap around and it's actually uh grass
isn't it as as approved on the
on your previous approved plans there
was a hard standing
area um
that wrapped around um
to roughly equal with
the rear elevation of the neighbours
extension that you can see there
so let me just go to the plan on this
um i don't i mean i have to check
whether
there's any further information about
what the intention is here but certainly
has approved on the previous
commission that there was a hard surface
area that was wrapped around the
building yeah
yeah that's what i've just i was just
squaring because the grass was on i
noticed the grass rather than the uh
conditioning unit so now so says
perhaps for nursery aged children not an
appropriate
place to have a
covered play area just as an observation
thank you
thank you councillor hartley
[Music]
yeah i had the same queries council
thomas actually in terms of it being
grasped i mean it does it does say in
the report that
that area was previously there was a
trim trail there and outdoor play
equipment um
so it sounded as if it certainly got a
history of
being used as a as a play area um
it is close to boundary but i don't i
don't think it's for us to
comment on how appropriate that area is
for children to play and that's that's
not a
planning consideration i don't think and
i think on planning grounds
there's no uh there's no reason to
refuse permission for this the aircon
units um
they do they do face the neighbors at
one two one first road or three of them
do but
the condition that that mitigates
against the impact of that you know is
very strict and will reduce the noise
level to
um below the background noise level i
think so
that that impact is is completely
mitigated in my view and the canopy um
is in accordance with the sort of
recommendations around security so it's
more than two meters from the boundary
um
i suppose it is a change in the use of
that area um
from
how it looks like it's used at the
moment supposed to actually know how
it's used but it's it's been used as a
player in the past
and
it could be used as a player again
without the need for the canopy but i
guess what the canopy does is you know
facilitate it to be used in inclement
weather so they'll probably be
intensification of use in that area but
it's a school but what i always come
back to on these sorts of applications
is it's a school site children play on
school sites um
the school don't need to make any
application to designate areas of the
grounds as areas to plane or not so that
that could happen anyway
um
so i simply don't think there's any
grounds to
um refuse planning permission for this
and i think there were good grounds to
grant it um allows the full use of the
school site it's an expanding school
um in in other parts of the site so yeah
i i think there's there's good reasons
to to approve and and to grant
permission with the conditions that are
in place and
i know the objective mentioned receiving
abuse from parents and the like again
they're not planning considerations but
um
you know i know the school it's not in
my ward and i know the
local pcsos would look at that if you go
in touch with them they've done that
before i know so um if that helps the
residents concerns then that might be uh
useful to know so yeah i think um i'm
happy to propose that we grant um we
agreed a recommendation to ground thank
you
thank you and miss coley's just gonna
find a little bit of clarification um
just wanted to clarify the point about
the playground and where children can
play when you're looking at a use of
land you look at the planning unit and
here the planning unit is the school and
therefore school activities can take
place anywhere on that planning unit
therefore children's play could take
place in that area at any point thank
you
thanks um councillor hassan
thank you
i don't think any problem to grant this
permission the only one very small point
i would
ask the offices to clear
in my point of view i mean
about
air conditions i mean the noise and
environmental i mean all of the things
are perfectly fine the only thing which
i i think
three then five air conditions may be
affecting the noise to the
the neighbors there are what is the
parameter how do
how do they establish that it will not
affect noise and environment when there
are about five or six eight editions
working between skills and the neighbors
there
so how do they how does the noise
how we can mitigate the noise
yeah five or six air conditions
uh simultaneously working at the same
time and then making big noise
yeah i mean obviously it's for
the noise impact assessment required by
the condition to
to look at that just like um obviously
assess what the actual
noise level would be and also what the
background noise levels
are because obviously it's the
difference that
is important and then um suggest
mitigation measures but it is possible
that might include some kind of acoustic
barrier around the um
air conditioning units but i mean we
don't have that information at this
stage okay so there are many
any kind of special manufacturer units
those who don't make any noise at all or
something we can recommend or
i mean obviously
five six scale creations are working and
the neighbors are there only few yards
then this is only my point
uh as we can recommend and otherwise
perfectly fine well what one factor
obviously is that the air conditioning
units are in place um already
um but i'm not aware that there are
okay a type of air conditioning unit
that don't create
any noise i don't know i might be wrong
about that
thank you
thank you my counselor a minute
thank you chair um
to be honest the i mean children schools
and playing children play all over the
playground in schools um um you know the
willows in my ward and
children play right up to the boundary
which is where there's a resident right
next door
it's not really to be a thing uh to be
concerned about um to me it looks like
actually if you had if it does turn into
hard standing there uh where that grass
part is and you have a canopy it'll
probably be used for things like
scooters and things like that to go
along because it's not exactly a very
sort of it's not extremely wide but it's
probably that sort of area i think it's
perfectly fine um i don't really see any
issue with that um yeah the air
conditioning units
there's going to be the noise impact um
assessments after anyway and fight to
find out the difference as it were so i
think that all the
issues in that way have been looked at i
don't see what the pressure so i'm happy
to propose that we actually um
that we accept officer recommendation
and grant this application
thank you i'll record that as you second
in counsellor
council thomas did you still want to
okay that's fine thank you um no one
else is looking to speak and we can move
to a vote on this
okay the motion the
the application be granted permission in
line with officer recommendation if
members supporting that motion can
indicate now please
okay yeah make that unanimous thank you
but now turn to application 107 614
moreland's junior school in sale which
can be found on page 111 of the
committee report before we turn to the
discussion the application is going to
be introduced by ms milner
thank you chair
so this application relates to
mullins junior school which occupies a
corner site between temple and broad
road in sale the application is for the
construction of two temporary classrooms
in the playground to the rear of the
main school building the school is due
to be expanded with a separate planning
application now live and which is noted
in the additional information report for
wider
works to the school
and the current proposal is to have
temporary classroom space to facilitate
the decant of the school building during
the works and the application is being
reported to
the planning and development committee
because traffic counselors the applicant
and two objections have been received
letters of objection have been received
relating to existing car parking in high
range highway arrangements and an
additional concern for the wider
redevelopment and
the local hiring authority have been
consulted and have raised no objection
on the fact that the proposal is to
facilitate the decal rather than
additional
um classrooms at this stage and
a full consideration of the impacts of
the further expansion of the school will
be received will be and will take place
in the um the future application
and while scenario playground would be
lost in the short term
um as you can see um this would be
placed on this the playground and
a large area would still be retained
along with the playing field a mugger
and a um kind
of
wild area of play um to the rear
um the sighting scale and appearance of
the proposed classroom is considered
acceptable given the temporary nature
and distance to surrounding residential
properties it's therefore considered
and the proposal accords the development
plan and is acceptable subject to the
conditions within the report thank you
thank you very much um there's no
speakers of this account from the
minister you want to open the discussion
it's clearly
unnecessary um
uh sort of like temporary classroom to
so they can actually do the extension
works to the school so i don't see why
why we wouldn't uh you know i would have
any issue with this i think we need to
support our schools so i by proposing
that we can
we can move on and accept the
application
thank you councillor thomas please
thank you chair i'm quite happy to
second that proposal um
the car parking issues are a matter for
council perhaps elsewhere with the safer
roads and safe streets that have been
successfully implemented in my ward
and we should perhaps look at rolling
that out to ease residents but in terms
of the proposal i see no issue with it
at all
thank you very much and councillor
welton
thanks chair i i think uh and we can
congratulate you on your new role and
say that there's a lot of issues here
that are for you and your
in that role but maybe not for us right
now so yeah happy to support this one
okay wonderful thank you um i can't see
anyone else indicating so we'll turn to
a vote the motion is the
permission be granted for this
application in line with officer
recommendation members supporting that
motion can indicate now please
okay make that decision unanimous so
with that um agenda item 6 is concluded
gender item 7 is a stopping order on
elsinore road in stratford and we do
need to note the report and the request
is that no objections be raised um the
order is just going to be introduced by
mr
thank you chair um yeah we're here this
evening just to ask permission by
members for
stopping up
closing off of a footway um to
facilitate a development which was
granted on the 5th of may
2021 and for 367 units and we just seek
your approval please
anybody have any comments on the
something called
nope i don't i'm happy to propose that
we
accept that and that's seconded by
councillor morgan
then members supportive of that can just
indicate
fantastic so and make that decision
unanimous um
that concludes agenda item seven
i don't think we've had any urgent
business tabled no um so with that i
just wanted to um
say that this will be my last meeting on
this committee and
just to express to you all um my thanks
and gratitude for your support and also
your patience with me over the course of
the last year it's really appreciated um
so thank you very much
and then with that meeting can be closed
oh